46 percent of us won dwayne johnson as
president as he floats potential run
newsweek story at least 46 percent of
americans would support
a presidential run from dwayne the rock
johnson according to a new poll the
actor and former presidential wrestler
has hinted that
could be a 2024 candidate for several
years
a poll by pips people say
suggest that nearly half of all u.s
adults would support his candidacy
the poll found that 29 would support
campaigns both by johnson for president
and actor matthew mcconaughey for texas
governor the poet conduct poll was
conducted
amongst 30 138 adults between april 2nd
and april 4.
johnson tweeted not sure our founding
fathers ever envisioned a six-four ball
tattooed
half black half samoan tequila drinking
pickup truck
driving fanny pack wearing guy joining
their club but if it ever happens it
would be my honor to serve the people
he's doing it there is absolutely no
doubt he
will run for president the only the only
question is what year
will it be he will run there's no
there's no doubt there's zero doubt
he just said it he says if the people
want me to duh
it's already happening all right i'll
tell you another thing the rock is bored
okay he's probably the busiest guy in
the world but he's bored as hell and
i'll tell you why
no offense but he doesn't make great
movies
i mean he makes good movies he makes
franchises jumanji bro he makes
action movies but it's the same thing
he's not winning academy awards
he's done what you can do making movies
he's bored with it and i'll tell you
another thing
he was ten times more entertaining as a
wrestler i mean right now he's like a
politician where he wants to please
everybody and he's
you know he's he's very good at that
he's the best the best in the world
but there was nobody like the rock when
it came to wrestling there was not
a single more entertaining person on
this planet
than dwayne johnson when he was a
wrestler if i was always hoping
there was every great point there was
never a doubt for me that he was going
to be a huge movie star
my disappointment was he didn't carry
that rock persona over
into acting it always became i'm going
to try this acting i'm going to take it
serious i'm dwayne johnson
but he's going to run for president and
he'll probably win and i'll tell you why
because this works
politicians that come from hollywood
works because it's an outsider you have
the the name
clint eastwood mayor of carmel and he
was successful arnold
schwarzenegger governor of california
very very successful
ronald reagan president of the united
states one of the greatest ever i think
he's going to do it and i think he's
going to win
and by the way just so you know neither
reagan
or arnold was as famous as the rock was
correct
that's what i'm saying no no no no he
was a bias
president of sag president only person
that's close to rock
yeah and arnie arnie was probably maybe
the biggest movie star at one time
arnold schwarzenegger good old arnie
barney
that's your boy yeah yeah i mean i can
just i can see it now he starts off
every
press conference he shows up and he goes
can you smell
what the rock is cooking
i kind of butchered that one but there
it was i could see him saying can you
smell
but i think number let's talk about the
things he has going for
number one number two number three is
name recognition are you kidding me like
you can run for president you have the
best ideas ever you know let's just pick
on
andrew yang yeah you had great ideas
maybe you didn't like them maybe you
like them or not ubi what have you
bringing tech bringing math but nobody
knew who it was we had no chance yeah
tom delaney whoever this guy was exactly
you don't know who he is he has name
recognition
but i think the biggest thing that he
has going for him is there is a
huge hunger and appetite in this country
for a third party the third party lane
is completely
open i mean i don't know if he's going
to run as a damn question
like who knows yeah but the guys get so
much money he'll have hollywood behind
him he'll have people
clearly donating the guy there's just
such a
the middle lane is wide open let's not
forget if he is going to run i think
that he would run as a democrat because
hollywood if you're listening to this
does he run as a democrat or a
republican or independent comment below
i'm curious
and then let's just not forget it was
maybe six months ago where goes where is
he
where is he and he starts getting crazy
like he's freaking on batman movie
talking about trump yeah
so he obviously is not a fan of trump
calling out trump but in my opinion did
you believe him
oh i believe he's an actor did
i don't think he likes trump i'm just
put that i don't think he likes trump
but i also don't think he likes biden
yeah i think he likes buying more than
trump i mean he remembers he
have to come out and do that because
i don't know if you ever watched the
interview trump
rock is very careful with his words go
and watch the five-minute clip of him
kamala and biden he didn't go out there
and fully
endor i don't know he says well we hope
that you're going to be able to go out
there and do the best things
he never fully supported it where's rock
on the political schedule center left
he's sent a right to me center right
he's exactly
where i am is i think where he's at okay
except i don't think he can be allowed
about it right he can't
here here's what to look at if he runs
as a democrat he's not putting hollywood
in his rearview mirror
if he runs as an independent it means
he's done with hollywood because you
can't go back
i don't think you could go back to
hollywood it will destroy him they will
destroy if he runs as what uh
if he runs as an independent he's done
in hollywood in my opinion if you run as
an independent and it's that freaking
bad to run
into i think so i don't know i think if
you run as a republican yes
if iran is an independent no no not as
an independent i don't think you can but
let me let me let me give you let me
give you a quick
question here and half statement here
running as an independent what are you
really saying
are you more center left or center right
right traditionally a little more center
right
exactly so but bernie sanders is
independent and
there's far from bernie sanders is
independently a socialist that's what he
is independent socialism
caucus is with the uh he caucuses with
socialists and communists that's what he
caucuses with period
democratic socialism right okay got it
let's raise taxes to 90
that's very democratic yes but let's go
back to the rock here let's go back to
the rock here
uh i i um i think he's got too many
people
in his ear that put way too much
pressure
on him i think he deep down inside is a
people pleaser and what i mean by this
is let me say this in the most
respectful way possible
i think he loves his mom and his family
obviously the guy is a
total family guy but his dad pushed him
a lot and he loves his mom
so he's got a soft place in his heart
for women a hundred percent i think the
guy is going to be very protected there
so if women come in
and tell him it's not fair it's not fair
it's not fair he may kind of
be tipping to that side so on any social
issues when it comes to women i think
he's going to support them
i think lgbtq i think he's going to
support them
uh military he's pro-military that's
what's so strange about it he's a he's a
pro-military guy fighter man so he's
going to support them not only a fighter
he's he's pro-america he's got flags of
america
everywhere he's going to get heat for
that and criticism for that
economically he's made a lot of money
that's going to be on the right side
economically
but if if if if he becomes himself to
run
if he becomes himself to run he'll make
change he'll make enemies
but if he becomes who everybody in
hollywood wants him to become to run
i think he'll be miserable i think he
will be miserable
one time uh he was doing an interview
with oprah winfrey
and somebody was asking him a question
about what happened between his marriage
when it fell apart you know when
you know it didn't work out all this
other stuff and i don't know if you've
seen this interview
you can tell he really wants to say the
right thing
like he is so concerned about saying the
right thing okay
so much about saying the right thing i i
and by the way the the
the part with him that i think it could
fully be pulled off
and he can be a generational type of a
leader
because i think what trump could have
done
to unify this guy could pull off now
do i think the rock can go up against
china and negotiate like i think trump
could negotiate with china absolutely
not
do i think rock could do that i don't
think so i think he's going to give she
the people his elbow
no i don't think so i don't think he
might suck him right in the shower i
don't think so because a lot of his
movies that he did in the last recent
years it was about china movies and he
was getting paid twice the amount of
money of what he would have done if it
was just the u.s
well once you start running for
president you you throw out your
your life i get that listen i'm telling
you for me i'm an optimistic guy
i'm a guy that's an optimistic guy and
i'm a guy that's a fan of his
uh uh his story is a fantastic story
it'd be a great story for kids to grow
up saying i want to be
like you know president you know
dwayne johnson when i grow up it's going
to be one of those things if he pulls it
off
but i hope he comes out with some
policies to protect
taxes protect the military and still
figure out a way to tell both sides
you're a little too extreme you're a
little too extreme i'm gonna be right
here
a couple of quick thoughts i do agree
with you that i think he
is a uniter and i think he would be able
to unite the country
capitalists hollywood leftists liberals
uh flag you know all that i do i do
believe that
versus you know previous president who i
think was a divider
and that's more of a macro perspective
and then just something just a little
tidbit
that i'm going to throw in there is a
little ps don't forget where the rock
went to college
university of miami what is the biggest
swing state in the country
florida florida for the last few
elections has gone
to the to the right a little bit of red
a little bit of red but you know florida
is probably the most purple state in the
country
you know for the north tallahassee where
i went to college a little more
conservative panhandle the white trash
riviera they call it up there down south
a little more
liberal obviously trump's here in
mar-a-lago so
i think he has the ability to make
florida the tipping point
if you wanted to do that he's way bigger
clearly bro he's got to run in 50 states
but florida
is a tipping point in any election if he
runs i don't think he'd need it i really
don't
here's what i would say about the rock
and to your point pat when he was a
wrestler he was so comfortable in his
skin because that was the family
business he knew it he knew it growing
up he knew it in and out
when he was in hollywood at the
beginning stages and even now he's
trying to conform to a certain degree
now he's just so damn talented and he's
so charismatic you know he's so good at
promoting and everything he's and he
does well in the types of movie he picks
that he's going to be super successful
my fear is that he would do the same
thing in politics that he's doing in
acting
is is trying not to offend trying to
just be a better
alternative than what we've had lately
go in there and kick some ass
and make some changes and don't care
what people say here's what he should do
career advice
101 for the rock run as a democrat
emulate john f kemmeny all right there
you go
john f kennedy you know you do that you
you kind of follow that game plan
you know where you can play both sides a
little bit you're you're going to get
that hollywood money
which you need you cannot turn your back
on hollywood you just can't do that if
you're the rock
or wall street and i think there's a way
to do it you don't have to be the same
type of democrat i think
republicans would embrace someone that
was a little bit not so crazy of what
we've seen on the left side lately yeah
i think if he goes that way
he is going to conform and he's not
going to be the president if he goes
that way
i think you're right if he wants to if
he wants to be
having that check mark of hey i'm
verified i'm 47.
i'm 48 whatever if he wants to have that
check mark which only 47 48 people i've
ever had in the world which is being a
president of the greatest country in the
world fine then go take that route
but if you want to be the kind like a
lincoln if you want to be a kind like a
churchill
if you want to be a kind where history's
talk about you for hundreds of years
where you become a legend
forever and ever and ever to come yeah
you may want to run
with your core values deep down inside
and go back and remember what your mom
and dad taught you and what you were
raised by
that made you who you are today the
hard-working mother you know what that
he is
and that's what that's what a lot of
people around he's hard-working guy
no excuses that's already center-right
okay that's a libertarian philosophy
you don't have to make excuses you can
make it work you have to improve
yourself this is
all center-right philosophies he doesn't
act like a victim he's not a victim he
doesn't make excuses he never says
poor me look what happened to me i don't
have any money bail me out this is a guy
that's coming out saying i'm going to
figure out a way to go straight to the
top so can
you my fan that you're watching me here
and i'm going to kick your ass and
challenge you and inspire you to do the
same as well
i think if it's history sure you got to
do it a different way yeah
if it's just a check mark go by the
playbook that you just said
i agree he would be a president i
totally agree with you on the on the
values and principles there because i do
think he has a core set of values
i just like the guy a lot let me like i
get people that say how can you say this
you know he's such a dude stop i like
the guy i mean people don't understand i
like you a lot
you know your your our relationship is
uh grown into what it is today
i like you a lot we may not agree
politically but i like you a lot i like
rock yeah i like rock as a guy as a dude
as who he is
uh i hope he uh makes the best of it
last thing
does it concern you at all yeah that
that
we haven't brought this up and no one's
really brought this up
that we haven't talked about policies
perspectives
he's not even needed it yet though no
meaning
the fact that you've never been the
mayor of a
little town or a governor of anything or
a center had never been
is that a good thing is that a bad thing
not knowing how washington works like
at least trump has donated to a million
different
people in one of the most political
industries in the world which is
which is hollywood are you kidding me
this guy's been playing politics
for 20 years dealing with the guy wwe
a very political organization the fact
that he made it around mcmahon and
was able to be the face yet not lose
credibility with mcmahon and mcmahon was
still the show this is all politics
the rock's been in politics for 30 years
no one just knows about it this guy may
be one of the best politicians we have
in america
politician i didn't say policies he may
be one of the best politicians we have
in america
the last 30 years i'm willing to bet
some of rock's best friends are
republicans
and democrats and independent and gay
and straight and pro-military and not
military
i'm willing to bet this guy is one of
the best politicians that last 30 you
know
bottom line is does he have your vote i
don't know yet i don't know
about you i have no idea but i will say
this my fear
today in apr april 13th is my fear is
that
he's a doer he's a driver he likes
checking those boxes i think he would do
it to
show that he could do i don't think he
can do anything and not be great at it
so i think he wants to be
the biggest at everything and that means
president i don't know at this point if
i think he'd be a great president i
don't know that
but i will say this pat if you're
hosting the debate in four years you get
all your questions right from this
podcast question you know today
you got the rock here in a presidential
debate you can ask them some of these
questions
yeah i mean we listen the rock's got an
open invitational valuetainment he just
has to ask for but i know
i know his camp will say don't sit with
this guy
okay because he asks weird questions
don't go sit with everybody that's gonna
ask basic questions but
uh i'm a fan i'm a supporter anything we
can to help spread his message whether
we agree or not we'd love to entertain
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]